[Music]
lovely thank everyone welcome spit that
I enjoy it the most
this is our lightning talks we have five
of them up to date like talks day like
talks tomorrow they have five minutes to
describe something interesting to us and
we keep them very much that time we'll
give you a one minute warning for the
end and obvious itting there and we're
pretty militant about it so you don't
see the consequences but Sammy ready to
go lever stuffs all right and go okay
probabilistic timeseriesforecasting with
facebook profit i'll unpack that this is
just me kicking the tires on a on a
package that Facebook released I think
like three three months ago and so it's
my details here and there's a notebook
and we can find the sort of this is
material so this old problem something
happened yesterday will it happen to
tomorrow tomorrow as ton tons of people
you know what worked on this and we've
all worked on this term so this is just
to have a picture in your mind of where
we're going this sort of his some time
series stages actually I'm over new New
York data and the number of trips on the
y-axis and this package is just trying
to model that time series data so you
can kind of predict away hey we've got
this sort of growth and sort of useful
for modeling you know demand and for
these detox services so here is here is
a facebook profit landing page you can
find that and just just search for that
this sort of got some basic
documentation and it's available in
quite in an hour and there's a paper as
well describing the model and there's
day we're on github
three thousand stars to the right of the
day together and Facebook get the word
out very well about their their
libraries and there's lots of people who
seem to like this so here it is these
guys made this this modest this library
its modeling just a single time theory
for the daily timestamp and it's got a
scikit-learn like API so sort of fit
predict
and under the hood it's got stand doing
probabilistic modeling of the model
parameters and if you help sort of get
the uncertainties on the forecast and
the actual time series model has these
like a linear or nonlinear growth with
change point detection and specification
so sort of Facebook might release a new
features that they want to kind of
impose a constraint on on this model say
things are changing our to this and
there's these weekly and yearly periodic
and components modeling for space and
they don't have a daily component yet
and you can also specify holidays and so
like the Super Bowl or and some other
things going on so it takes two pandas
dataframe as input and you've got these
model parameters that go in the change
points and the holidays and then the
output is this data frame with forecasts
and uncertainties and the model
components you can sort of look at look
at what those individual components look
like so I've done a demo just
aggregating this sort of freedom of
information in form in 14 million
overrides and that Nate Silver sort of
got hold of some sometime in 2015 you
can get the details there so just as a
look at the the API there you've got the
sort of it's like you're familiar with
that from from scikit-learn you
instantiate the model and you fit on the
data and you can sort of make a future
to sort of do some forecasts and then
you know plot the models and that's what
I what I showed you showed you before so
it's a very sort of clean clean access
to this this model you can inspect the
components so the top top one is we've
got sort of time and then there's this
sort of trend component and you can see
the change points there these are the
holidays the holiday components so it
seems in this inrease in this model
those those federal holiday there was
less less rides for uber on those days
and then you've got this weekly
component down here and so manages at
Wednesday you can see you've got a high
signal high signal to noise detection of
the fact that at this time in New York
people sort of using for more on like
Friday Friday and Saturday relative to
Monday and Tuesday so this at 7:00
that's pretty much the end of
my presentation was just to sort of walk
you through and what what what a what a
facebook profit and looks like so that's
that's everything thank you so I'll just
be quickly evangelizing about this new
tool for helping you use pukin notebooks
in circles source control better so if
you are here for the tutorials yesterday
one of the negative things about gupta
notebooks was it difficult to use them
in source control like it so i'm here to
tell you that if it in the last year we
hopefully made a solution that will help
you use Scripture notebooks in source
control like k so here I've taken a
you're going to do a live demo from one
of the repositories that we used for the
tutorial yesterday the click paste
tutorial so I ran this and then we
generated the output so I wanted to see
you know if you use standard gate and to
try to tell you what this change you get
a lot so you can see here there's a lot
of metadata that is change and you could
keep going there's a lot of stuff that
has changed that was an image that big
blob of green text there was a figure
that was added this is an HTML table and
there is some more metadata here at the
end so that's the existing tool if you
use git diff if I now use our tool and
I'm going to add this one option here
saying I just want to see the source
differences I want to see what has
changed in the source it gives you a
nice print saying that we added this one
cell and it has this source and you can
also say give me everything except
metadata oops too the typo
and it will give you here to offer the
output still it's you know quite a bit
of a big dump but at least if you go up
the things like de big images has been
instead of the base64 string you've been
replaced by just a snippet saying this
has changed so you don't get a huge
basics before input up and of course if
you're not working in the terminal but
want to work on in the web browser like
we normally would do with the Drupal
notebook you also have to have a web
interface for this where you can say
that here we've added a cell with this
source and down here we actually ran
this cell and we got this this output
down here this is a table isn't is
rendered as it would be in a notebook
and you can see the unchanged cells here
here you can see the figure that was
added this base64 thing and then another
output here and so that's the distinct
part we also have added a merged driver
for those of you who use the normal git
merge driver if you see this that you
have a conflict previously that would
often mean that now your jupiter
notebook was corrupt and you couldn't
open it anymore so with our new driver
we do this intelligent dis and
intelligent merge if i now open up this
notebook that is in conflict it is
actually a valid notebook and if you
scroll down you can see that this is the
output as added this is the previous you
can see that the only thing that
actually change was the text plain
representation and not the actual PNG
that means that just the in memory hash
that the drupal that the eye patent uses
internally has changed which is normally
uninteresting and then you can see here
in the source you get this normal merge
markers inside the actual source you can
see i just change here a line saying
plot with the green color instead of a
blue and then you can see the output
further down with the changed call so
now hopefully both merging and and
dissing should be a lot easier for you
if you use this tool and it just called
NB dine for notebook dipping and merging
just the first letters of getting and
murdering so if you google that
install envy diamond should hopefully
work release the new version on
yesterday so hopefully you know so that
should be a pretty pretty mature now in
terms of release so yeah alright that's
all I have so thanks for attention
ty my talk is I'm also gonna talk about
Jupiter notebooks but not how you can
upload into and get repository of like
that's something actually much more
simple just until my slides come up so
when I was an academic I never used
Jupiter notebooks I don't know how I
used to work without it now I I'm in
private sector it's as you know its life
saver I'm preaching to the choir just
before so I'm basically going to explain
one work workflow system that I
developed for myself which is quite
simplistic and that's what I'm going to
explain right now just before I start
this anybody did anybody hear of running
PI or use it
show of hands running Phi oh okay so one
hand so if I get one convert today then
I did my job so basically what is it
what happens is we do it at the
exploratory phase and you're ready to
put on mass produce a product for a
client and some let's say some sort of
analysis but you in my case for example
I analyze one state in the United States
would say I do it on New Jersey but then
I want to extrapolate it on ten other
states
well one can make the argument well you
did it in the Jupiter notebook will
download it as a PI script and just run
it over in parallel that's all nice but
what you really want to do is use the
dopers do the strength of jupiter
notebook to log everything all the stats
of interest all the figures and that's
where i find a module like running pi is
very useful and what it is basically
takes advantage of the fact that jupiter
notebook is just a JSON file and so you
can run it with running PI can run it
from from the batch line and so you can
feed it variables and things like that
so I do so what I did in in a few
projects is what I do is I do my like in
one notebook I do my analysis until I'm
happy and then I want to mass produce so
then I can
just clone everything and I I can
paralyze it and use running pine in
order to feed in order to feed a
parameter for example I want to Arkansan
that I want to do
Arizona etc and then well I don't want
to go over 20 or maybe 50 different
notebooks just to see if something went
wrong and special care well then what I
do is I create a master notebook in
which I pull the information from from
the notebooks where just JSON files I
use a different module called env format
in which you just pulled out all the
information focus on whichever cell you
want for example here I focus on these
figures and that way I can get a quick
review of what I've done so yeah so I
really liked it so I like using it and I
became lazy ad constantly using this
running PI and so I just wrote a a sweet
wrapper around it that I call Jupiter
stream so I put into the git repository
so feel free to take a look and I also
wrote a short vlog about it which I
posted already on slack so that's it
thank you so this is my claim captures a
debt and what I mean by that is captures
like this so maybe you've seen that
before this is quite an image and I
didn't get this capture but the goal is
to mark all the the dogs and to tell
them from the muffins and it's it's not
easy I mean it's possible but this thing
here for example is very hard so what
are various very I've more of them
hopefully you have time so my ideas is
it that is a capsule to tell the machine
from the human but is it at all possible
for something that Google created that
Google actually can also do this and I
made an experiment and I use the pre
trained inception model that you can
just download from Google it's based on
tensorflow
it's very easy to setup and I fit in
this talk and I ask you what is this and
drum roll we think sushi Vava I had no
idea that this is a Shiva but obviously
it is 70%
good right second dog little bit harder
but more cute maybe Chihuahua
94% not bad right but now this I did
this this afternoon and I was very
surprised cool has no idea what it is I
think it's a boss but only with 5% so it
has no idea that's what is telling us
but it's knows for sure this is not a
dog
good second one this is very hard I
thought Google would fail on us here but
that's a teddy bear but I mean 25% and
then custard apple I don't even know
what that is umm spaghetti squash also I
don't know I'm German I have no idea umm
but it knows for sure this is not a
chavala so what I did I got more
examples and they are harder there it's
also on this is not my joke it's a stone
joke so this one I got wrong because I
thought it was a loaf of bread but it
has feet this actually is a dog and it's
very mean because those are all dogs
bottoms there's talk behind and I was
very surprised so let's see I have many
more of them is that the dog versus
bread right let's see so the first dog
but no mistake how does the first dog
look like this one let's see zoom in
that's really hard right I mean this is
I mean who makes pictures like this I
don't know I don't do this but it's it
helps us it's avenged Kogi and have no
idea about dogs but I think it is right
almost 50% from from from telling from
the behind on the dog I'm a so I know
idea I didn't try this until this
afternoon second dog I think this is
even harder right this is the one I got
wrong because I didn't see its feet
let's see I'm running out of time but I
have to show you I mean
this thing I mean that is dog a weight
and I think Google also thinks this is
not a dog let's see I'm running this one
from command line are very not powerful
machine Etsy give it some time
yeah well it doesn't think it's a dog
but they think it's a rabbit or person
can but it doesn't think it's Brad so at
least and now I tried it again the other
way around with a branch thing and this
thing I think this is the hardest one
right well this is very hard to know
what is out of context right at least
that's what I thought it could be a dog
but it's a loaf of bread that's C and
this is I mean I'm not faking this you
see this right so this is the second
bread let's see what it tells us
come on French low 99% not bad right I'm
running out of time but I've more
samples I'm just showing you the samples
this is chicken bingville is cool this
is it's funny right I mean this one was
this one it's happy right and they're
all so cute and this is the final one
this is bagel versus also dog and now
this this was this and I've tried I've
compared those two with very high
percentage this is dog this is bagel so
Google's very good at this retaining the
central so I would say captions are that
and with that thanks
[Applause]
hi so this is something a bit different
this is just a toy project anybody who
wants to write their own Twitter bot I
didn't until recently and why did I do
it because I was going to run a half
marathon and I wanted everything no I
was running a half marathon but what I'm
running I can't tweet doesn't work this
is the PI dated stream and if the live
demo actually works which is going to be
impressive because the you know this is
a will see if it oh yeah no it started
so this is actually now I'm live
tweeting my lightning talk so yeah this
is now foolishly me about three weeks
ago slightly different change of pace at
Southampton half marathon I want to
communicate it out so first up how do we
tweet I thought this was going to be the
really difficult bit no it isn't tweet
PI to the rescue if you've never used it
it's really straightforward I have
obviously put a load of fake consumer
keys and stuff there you cannot get into
my account um but it's very simple you
import the authentication tool you put
in whatever you get out of Twitter you
create your own little API and with one
command it's update status give it some
text and off it goes in to the ether
that is the internet and you get things
like Adam started like Lee Teuk
18:17 it's got five minutes who needs
emmalin when you've got something like
that to do the timing it the question
was though what did i want it to tweet
whilst i was going so this is a snapshot
from the Southampton half mountain from
their timing group I'm sure they're
really happy that I started hitting
their page this is the final results
that came through this page the day
before or the week before was empty of
numbers there pretty much so I just knew
what I was expecting so then it was the
joy of oh I've got them in a minute so
you can be temperance this is where you
go back to your classic scraping tools
so you can see that I'm pulling in
requests to go and get a web page a bit
of beautiful soup so I can go and mine
it that table is a nightmare but
eventually after a bit of trick working
your way through you can take it and
then the joy of pandas as we all depend
on it
haffley just converts into a nice table
for me so everything works out but now I
want to be able to monitor differences
in what's going on so I actually need to
store it so I'm not using anything big
so I'm going to push it out just to the
sake of it to a file so I'm going to use
sequel Lite that will take and again and
as it happily goes to sequel so connect
to my file pushes it out and the trick
becomes now I need to actually monitor
for updates so this is these are the
couple of functions I wrote I want to be
able to fit I can go and get my new
results I know from my web scraper I'll
go and fetch the last set of old results
if I had and then I do this little
comparison my check and if there's
something that's changed return the role
of the table let's come back with a
little flag of hasn't changed history
not changed and if it has then great I
can write to tweet and in this case
these are the things that were coming up
so I've started or I've managed to get
finally to the finish line or I'm just
slowly eating my way around the course
so all of those are all ready and then
because you know I wanted to make it
available to anybody else through my
friends although I didn't actually have
it debug before the race unfortunately
it only tweeted 5 days after the fact
hey I'm a perfectionist I wanted to
debug it so I put it all together in a
little class and that means that you can
just put your running bib number in it
we'll go and find your crooked page it
will go through will do everything it
will push things out it will pull it all
back and now having put all that in a
nice class hidden the winner the file I
can now do my half marathon in ten lines
of code create my Twitter bot create my
runner and what I haven't finished
running just go through and every five
minutes go and pull it out and I'm only
at the midway mark but there is the
equivalent of what popped out five days
after the half marathon but I started
and slowly my way through so if you want
to write your own Twitter bot go for it
the wheel joys that I think we may have
our own because this has been going
through my feet all day with a slightly
different account so somebody else is
using the PI data London tag at the
moment
and thank you very much all right so
last year uptight Asia London I managed
to pack two lightning talks into my one
lightning talks lot and I thought that
was kind of fun so I'm going to try and
make it my thing so once again I have
two lightning talks for the price of one
thank you and so lightning talk number
one we recently released - version six
- version six requires Python three if
you're still using Python - don't panic
- a Python version five will continue to
get bug-fix releases and laptop support
Python - however if you're using an old
version of Pitts and you go pip install
I pison on Python 2 then it will try and
get the newest version which is like
five and six and you'll get an error
message saying this version of ipython
is not compatible with Python - so
ladies and gentlemen this is a public
service announcement
keep your version of PIP up to date the
current version of PIP I think is nine
point eight point one if you're using an
older version run Pippin pip install - -
upgrade pip and that will get you the
newest tip automatically and pip itself
wants you to keep this thing up to date
all right
so slamming the brakes on lightning top
number one that was that now I move on
to the thing that I actually put down on
the signup sheet which might be
Bloomberg's authentication page there we
go
I had notes come on that and one moment
not the authentication page where's my
mouse gone there it is
there we go so leading in this is a cool
project that zombie demonstrated at a
height a [ __ ] stir down last month it
generates text that looks like it comes
from a target language but doesn't
actually mean anything it's a convenient
demo point for this bit for this talk
because it doesn't actually have any
tests it's just a little hobby project
of the guy who did it so it's not sort
of that's not too bad a thing but it
does have a couple of notebooks in there
which so this blog post type A & B
notebook for example exercises the
library and checks that the code there
is working and you know has an example
that it goes through of how to use this
and some output from it so the tool I'm
talking about and eval
you can use the the PI test framework
and you add this - - end eval lacks flag
and it will run those notebooks and if
any of the cells in the notebook produce
an error then it counts as a failing
test so this is a really easy way to add
tests to a project that doesn't already
have it and also - even if your project
does have sort of proper tests it's a
convenient way to exercise your examples
in your documentation to show you that
checks that they're still working so if
you change your code and it breaks your
examples then your continuous
integration setup can flag that up to
you and tell you this example is broken
you need to go and fix it
or fix the code that's appropriate and
going one step further
I can manage two screens at the same
time there we go so this is the the
notebook in question and if I put in
here in boo vowel check output so this
is a new cell tagging thing that was
introduced in Jupiter notebook 5 so I've
deliberately put this check output tag
on a cell that doesn't have
deterministic output so you normally
don't want to do this I'm going to do it
to show a failing test and it will now
run that and in addition to checking
that the cell doesn't produce an error
it will also compare the output from
running that cell against the output
that saved in the notebook and if they
differ then it will count that as a
failing test as well and you should see
in a moment fingers crossed if we have
time and it will come up with a
comparison of the output but I didn't
save it did I so if the test hasn't
failed if I had done this properly then
you would have seen that home let's see
if this see if there's still time before
it
okay there isn't going to be time but
what you will see is that yeah there you
go failing test is that it gives you a
comparison of the output that you should
have expected with the output and that's
actually produced so you get a nice view
of what's failing in your your example
test and I think I am out of time now I
had the bleeper going so thank you very
much oh go on
thank you guys there you go injury okay
before I get started I just wanted to
say that I think today's proceedings
have been amazing and just before I get
started I think we owe a round of
applause to all of the orange short
wollen tears for making this event
possible but do remember today is not
over so as Emaline noted we are going to
the pub and there will be a public with
we just finished writing the questions
about an hour ago when we did this in
Amsterdam it was incredibly popular but
the questions were too easy so we've
made them very challenging for you now I
plan to give I originally plan to give a
lightning talk tomorrow but whenever I
see lightning talk sign ups I feel
compelled to sign up I just can't get
enough of myself and if you can't get
enough of me either come to the Pope
quiz I promise you you will learn
something it's going to be really
exciting to some really cool questions
that said here's a lightning talk I
managed to put together about something
which is actually kind of useful but
nobody seems to care about I'll tell you
about it so I keep putting certain
smaller projects on github without
documentation or tests or an explanation
for what they are and nobody seems to
care about them I don't know why and so
here's one example of them for something
that is very small but it's actually
incredibly useful in practice it turns
out that I really like technologies
where you can get an enormous amount
done in about 100 lines of code I feel
there's something very powerful about
writing these technologies very close to
either the operating system or a core
platform or core language online
computer there is a directory called SRC
and it contains stuff like this and if
you look inside that directory you can
see something there's a directory called
code every time I see a package online
that I like I download the tarball for
the code
and I unzip it so I can look through the
code and in fact I there are a lot of
packages on github or I use arch for
this computer so on a you are there a
lot of packages and I might want to
download them so there's a lot of places
where I get raw source code sometimes I
want to tweak that source code so for
example there's small bugs or key
bindings which you can't change I just
want to comment outlines here they're in
the source code and so I have a folder I
put those tweaks sometimes I want to
build that source code you can see
there's nothing this directory
yet but sometimes I want to build them
and sometimes I want to install this but
I don't want to solve to my system
because I don't want to overwrite
something the system needs so you can
see I install node I install nginx I
install Postgres that's all kind of
interesting now what I'm going to show
you is how I actually managed to build a
lot of things from source and it's going
to look really crazy but it works for
over four hundred and sixty-four
separate things that I build from source
either in order to investigate something
or to debug something or as part of just
getting something to work where I needed
to do a small patch it turns out that
actually setting this up is very painful
and I want to be able to download the
raw source code applied tweaks
separately to them and then build them
without ever losing what the original
source code looks like what the tweaks
are and without and also being able to
determine what the install artifacts are
separate from what the original source
code was because in some cases when you
build something it doesn't build in a
separate directory so you get a bunch of
shared objects and a lot of intermediate
objects and you want to be able to
distinguish that from the raw source
code so I wrote a make file and it makes
all kind of looks like this and I give
all the directories for the code you
know the folders in the code record I
want to build and all the directories
for the folds of the arcs directory I
want to build and I can actually do some
kind of sophisticated things because in
the Python directory I say I build both
the Python 2 7 and a 3 5 with both
production and dev debugging features I
install a Python with dev features and
pod features and I actually even build a
separate Python for each individual
package that I use out of tips if it's a
major package now this doesn't look like
a normal make file you users make macros
in fact I wrote a meta make file that
has macros and the make macros just emit
make build rules to build these and what
happens when you run this is it
generates an actual make file so I have
a make file that creates a make file
so in it might make file I say make
concrete and it builds a make file now
why would I go through that extra step
well I really like tab completion and I
really like name spacing so this make
file actually has name spacing these are
all the build directories I can build
these are all the install directories I
can build because some of these install
the records are actually Union FS file
system D duplicating each other on top
of each other this works for over four
hundred and sixty-four packages that I
built now the good question would be
let's see it work so these are all the
things that I currently am building on
this system it generated all these build
directories it generated enormous number
install directories that generated some
tweaked directories I use arch which has
this download the source code make a
package it has about three steps before
you actually get the source code you to
build it did all of that automatically
from dependencies from fairly simple
make file generating make file who's
ever heard this phrase before a fairly
simple make file generating makes well
now the neat thing is if I want to the
dependencies are here so I can clean
everything up you can see this is using
Union FS so it automatically figures out
what it needs to mount and unmount in
order to make this work so when I do
make make all and I do mount you see all
my mount points you can see there's an
enormous number of mount points here I
have a separate Python built when I do
corporate training I have a Python for
just the library DNS clip a Python just
for the library curio and they just
stack on top of each other to duplicate
itself because this computer doesn't
have that much hard drive space now the
weird thing that you might wonder is I
had this install directory with all this
code right and inside this install
directory there's even a directory
called Python with all the Python
version so these are all the Python
versions I'm currently building on this
portable laptop now the question is how
do I actually run these well this all
came out of me looking at the to a
virtual I'm saying you know what I can
do my own version of that so here is an
86 lines of code a better virtual end
and what I say a better virtual it is
way better than richland this is on
github not a single person has ever
cloned this repo it has no documentation
it has no readme it just has a name but
this is one of the most useful tools in
my actual life all it does is it uses
the built-in end command to set up pass
library include path link or path man
path is the most it's as simple as super
thing it's just
she'll only but you could write your own
version or bash or ever so you want in
about 86 lines of code let me show you
what you can do with it
I installed anaconda using the standard
anaconda installer I say Tim - pee
anaconda which Python 3 it uses the
Python through from anaconda that just
works I use sometimes they do stuff with
react so I need node so I can say to
directories look which NPM I'll get the
NPM from the right place which Python 3
it gets that from the right place well
that's kind of nice in fact sometimes
for my environments I need to make it I
need to figure I need to use Postgres as
well so which psql Oh get 2 from the
right place so I actually have this kind
of mix-and-match build directories what
else can I do well virtual them gets you
into an environment well with pens it's
just the end command with some wrapping
around it so you just do this to get
into your virtual end and get out of
your virtual on just do control D
activate and deactivate or a clear
indication that whoever virtual em did
not understand how the shell work this
is how the shells supposed to work you
enter a sub shell and you leave a sub
shell two more slides with NPM you can
install something like gulp into node
modules what that gives you is a
directory that's based on where your
know modulus where your bin files are
with PEM you can evaluate an expression
within the currently building
environment so I can say use the node
pen the node environment is just a
directory with the source sorry the user
live etc construct the path from inside
that environment and then tell me where
my gulp is and it tells me my gulp this
and so finally you can do some fancy
stuff because anyone ever wanted to
figure out what is what are all the
binaries that exist at the very first
entry in my path well here you can do
that so that's temp nobody is that
nobody likes it if 86 lines of Z
shellcode plus a make file that
generates make files this is one of the
most useful tools for me it works for
every tool that I use it works for
JavaScript it works for no it works for
no doors for postcards works for Python
it is an incredibly useful and very
simple approach if you don't want to use
it it's ok I don't mind but I like it
so of course what we mentioned earlier
but we're going to get hired you've now
been hired into meta makefile Inc
they've raised Series A it's amazing
what you can do with the right people
and the right amount of money
thank you very much James right so this
gives you a few thank-yous and then
we'll all release ourselves the pub of
course as always we have to thank
Bloomberg thank you very much for
allowing us all of the space thank you
and I have to thank continue our little
man AHL pivot go jet brains into other
what did he win for side all right okay
yeah okay so we're gonna get ratings
before going Bloomberg or ecloudmanager
Hill and Cambridge spark fantastic great
so that's a lot of sponsors thanked it
thank you for all of our speakers for
all of our speakers who gave their time
today that basically makes a conference
and your speakers in the room still here
Google stand up get oh crap patter is
just you me she is parlor
thank you to all of our orange safety
shirt construction people for building
this thing very good and and thank you
very much to all of you attendees for
coming along and making a such an
excellent event I think that's done we
are over time thank you very much
everyone
[Music]